[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es eine Cola Torte ich hatte
mal vor Jahren eine Cola Flasche gemacht
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch dran die
war ziemlich cool aber heute gibt's
einen lockeren Coca-Cola Kuchen wobei
ich dazu sagen muss dass ich Cola gar
nicht abfeier gell ich trinke das auch
gar nicht das zweite Mal im Jahr habe
ich schon Lust auf so eine kalte Cola so
ein Schluck kalte Cola mehr kann ich
nicht aber ich weiß dass viele von euch
Cola mögen viele Cola Zero mögen
Fantakuchen können wir und Cola Kuchen
machen und es wird glaube ich ein
leckerer Kuchen ja die Zutaten sind auch
überschaubar dafür verwende ich zwei
Eier 100 g Zucker etwas Salz und
Vanilleextrakt 100 g Sonnenblumenöl 140g
Coca-Cola 200 g Mehl plus Backpulver
oder nimmt einfach das backmehl und 30 g
Kakao
und wenn ihr möchtet dass es eine Cola
Kirschtorte wird dann nehmt ihr gerne
noch 100 Gramm Kirschen aus dem Glas und
20 Gramm Stärke ist verrühre ich dann
später dann kommt nämlich noch ein
bisschen Kirsche mit in den Teig zuerst
nehme ich jetzt die Eier Zucker Salz und
Vanilleextrakt und die Zutaten werden
kurz in der Küchenmaschine verrührt
[Musik]
so sieht schon mal super aus es reicht
immer wenn die eierzuckermasse weiß
schaumig ist mit dem Handrührgerät
dauert es schon so vier bis fünf Minuten
mit der Küchenmaschine so ungefähr 1 bis
2 Minuten das geht echt schnell und
jetzt nehme ich das Sonnenblumenöl und
die Cola und hole das jetzt hier schön
ein
[Musik]
dann gibt die trockenen Zutaten auch
direkt dazu also Mehl plus Backpulver
grau und jetzt kurz verrühren nicht so
lange
das reicht schon ich habe jetzt hier
meine rehrückenbackform die ist ganz
hübsch ihr könnt auch die doppelte Menge
nehmen und zum Beispiel eine
Gugelhupfform benutzen ihr könnt Muffins
backen oder Mini Donuts ganz wie ihr
möchtet auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen
mit backtrennspray
hier einfetten
und dann hier schön rein füllen
[Musik]
dann so ein bisschen verteilen und wenn
ihr möchtet gerne die Kirschen dazu
geben und damit die nicht so ganz
untergehen für riecht sie einfach mit
Stärke
ein bisschen ummanteln
dann könnt ihr sie so ein bisschen
reindrücken
[Musik]
kommt der Kuchen schon in den
vorgeheizten Backofen bei 170 Grad
Ober-Unterhitze für etwa 30 bis 35
Minuten
der Kuchen ist abgekühlt ich habe ihn
schon aus der Form rausgestürzt und
jetzt einfach auf einem abkühlgitter für
die Glasur verwende ich 100 g
Puderzucker 20g Kakao 20 Gramm Coca-Cola
10 Gramm Kirschsaft und etwas
Zitronensaft
dann nehme ich jetzt hier alle Zutaten
und verrühre sie miteinander
[Musik]
okay
dann
gebe ich den Kuchen auf eine Platte
normalerweise drehe ich es immer gerne
um weil der Rehrücken ja so schöne
Rillen hat aber der ist jetzt auch da
oben richtig schön geworden so Vulkan
mäßig ich lasse es so
ich lass das so ja also ein bisschen
wollte ich schon dass die Kirschen
eintauchen habe ich ein bisschen gut
gemeint mit der Stärke ihr taucht die
einfach ein bedeckt das mit dem Teig und
dann sind sie wirklich eben Teig drin
jetzt nimm dir die Glasur und die kommt
da jetzt oben drauf
[Musik]
also ich muss sagen
der riecht schon gut nach Cola und damit
so aussieht wie eine Cola Torte habe ich
jetzt hier die kleinen Colaflasche
besorgt und die kommen da jetzt noch
drauf und dann kann der Kuchen probiert
werden
ich bin mal gespannt
wie der auch mir schmeckt und ich bin ja
wirklich ein nicht cola-liebhaber
es gibt eine Cola Pflanze die ist
ziemlich cool die werde ich diese im
Garten anbauen dann habe ich nämlich
eine Cola Pflanze die schmeckt und
riecht nach Cola da kann man sich so
eine eigene Limonade oder ein Wasser
machen aber man trinkt eben keine Cola
denn das ist halt schon
[Musik]
probieren
heute gibt's Cola Kuchen ein ein
Klassiker meine Kindheit echt ja aber
wir hatten nicht die original Cola wir
haben Topstar Cola gehabt
ich dachte so das ist so Fantakuchen
Cola Kuchen ich habe es erfunden echt
nee kannst du dich schon
schlimm aber ich glaube viel soll die
kennen das und nicht die Kinder sind
Cola hören es ist nichts gesundes noch
mal ganz wichtig zu sagen Cola ist
nichts gesundes aber es ist so die
Kinder flippen dann auch sagen oh cooler
Kuchen was ist das also ganz offen sagen
meine Kinder dürfen keine Cola
hat sich mal was bestellt dann
Spießer Familie sind ja ich bin schon
ein bisschen
Spieß
okay für mich
aber es geht natürlich auch ohne okay
probier mal okay
gut aus richtig
oder
als Kind fand ich immer was ist
Highlight wenn man dann diese Haribos
oder die Gummibärchen die Süßigkeiten
oben drauf so runter esse konnte in
jedem auf jeder Kindergarten
Geburtstagsfeier
und übrigens die Dinger gibt es
inzwischen auch im vegan ganz ganz
wichtig ist auch egal also auch eine
coole Geschichte ja noch mal ein Kuchen
ist eigentlich normalerweise nichts
Besonderes das ist egal
also cooler Geburtstagskuchen werden ja
also probiert gerne mal aus das Rezept
gibt's wie immer und in unserer App
schaut da gerne vorbei bis zum nächsten
Mal tschüss
oder nicht
[Musik]